alors on ne présente plus l'abbé de la
morandais vous étiez le meunier du monde
politique jusqu'à ce que vous
choisissiez balladur face à jacques
chirac
n'en va pas recommencer je vous présente
l'une mais c'est pas évident je vous
présente j'essaye de le présenter à mes
amis téléspectateurs qui regardent pas
toujours toutes les émissions devraient
donc vous étiez aumônier du monde
politique oui jusqu'à ce que vous
choisissiez balladur et quand chirac a
été élu j ai dit jamais choisi la fed
ainsi gilles a dit celui-là tu me virer
du style évidemment aux ors de l'elysée
vous à virer voilà vous vous êtes
retrouvé curé de l'aéroport d'orly un an
un an
ensuite beaucoup moins drôle vous êtes
devenu curé à gare de lyon oui populaire
au cordeau relie la gare de lyon bah
c'est pour partir toujours est toujours
ça vous êtes toujours à la gare de lyon
et je suis toujours mais il ya une tâche
très importante la base c'est qu'il y a
c'est pas très politique ça plaît ni à
la droite ni à la gauche mais il ya
plein de exclu il ya des sdf pas mes
femmes voilà donc je suis vice président
d'une association qui s'appelle la les
haltes des amis de la rue voilà nous
préparons être michel serrault un super
noël au musée d'art faisait arts forains
à bercy dans tous ces gens là mannequin
ses excuses voilà hommes et femmes qui
sont dans la misère totale la gauche
s'en fout la droite s'en faut je peux
voler heureusement que vous êtes là j'ai
pas dit ça alors vous êtes un curé assez
médiatique vous êtes jorien j'avais été
sur match télévision ennuis lui l'abbé
de la morandais c'est le porte parole de
l'église catholique ah bon
un infidèle
pendant le nourrain non parce que c'est
de là on a du mal un petit peu à suivre
les déclarations de l'église catholique
les positions de l'église sont
transmises par plusieurs porte parole il
n'ya qu'un porte parole officiel
monseigneur stanislas lalanne la lame à
double led monseigneur lalanne vous dira
que c'est vexant contre la loi sur le
voile donc l'église dition légifère on
va tout bouleverser laissons les choses
en l'état on va pas légiférer pour 1 %
de la population et pour des motifs
conjoncturels est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à une loi sur les signes
religieux à l'école oui pour une région
symbolique surface face à un islam un
islamisme un peu trop conquérant ardent
et prosélyte ils ne respectent pas la
laïcité française il faut marquer un
coup d'arrêt symbolique donc ça va donc
vous vous êtes pour la loi oui pour
interdire les signes religieux à l'école
louis contrairement à tous les pistes
copains français oui il ya un schisme
non me de long c'est un point de vue
libre et débattus bah oui mais lier un
schisme quand le dogme est en jeu ce
position dogmatique
vous devriez vous ranger derrière les
positions de l'église le cas de lens
c'est une question ouverte avant que
tout à fait bon monseigneur il existe
déjà des lois
depuis 1905 oui le père comblé la
séparation des résultats il existe des
lois interdisant les signes
religieux à l'école ouais donc vous vous
êtes contre une nouvelle loi vous
conseillait déjà eu les appliquer
c'était
juste un verre mais juste un verre et
pas le contraire c'est contre la loi je
suis pour la loi celle inverse non et
voilà que je devais en retenir la loi du
marché de la loi
mon frère et ma télé linverse et on lui
dit il ya une loi lui noah monseigneur
louis moncet seigneur doit
alors un peu de respect à cette équipe
son altesse serena ses norias non mais
c'est bon je crois qu'ils sont sa porte
ou les deux mosquées n'ont donc ici d'un
verre dont il dit il ya une loi mais
n'est pas appliqué le
contraire une loi le nepad a ajouté
qu'il était jaloux et loire pareil des
édiles inverse au ccnr monsieur le
frère cadet
il n'y a bien averses et lotader
monsieur maintenant c'est la mer non
avec son venin je crois que tu as ouvert
cette eau est ce qu'on a le droit
d'aller à l'école avec une paire de
lunettes mouche ils ont peur
il ya longtemps que l'on avait pas vrai
qu'on va les faire l'émission vient de
torres qu'elle a le droit d j'avais pas
la laisser comme ça j'ai fait ce qu'on
peut avec avec des cheveux de cette
couleur annoncé le contraire et mes
cheveux mi longs mais vous savez quoi on
dirait du renard
les renards argentés ou alors vous êtes
pour la lutte contre la loi vous je suis
humain je suis pour le prochain je suis
pour le projet de loi que préparent les
politiques et monseigneur et contre je
vais quand même qu'un évêque qui a été
interdit de deux photos d'identité sur
m'écoute et me rendais oui je vous
écoute il ya un effet à mon père à ses
côtés il
ya un évêque qui a été interdit de
photos d'identité parce qu'ils voulaient
faire une photo avec un petit col romain
comme vous quand même c'est grave c'est
que ça s'est passé nous enfin il faut
dire qu'il avait que ça
en 1905 après la loi de 1905 les
soutiens étaient interdites dans la rue
et tout ça non mais ce phénomène ne pas
mélanger la sultane elle connaît pas
quand j'ai été aumônier du monde
politique suit à l'assemblée nationale
dans cette tenue on m'a toujours accepté
bien si le règlement de l'assemblée
nationale oblige à une cravate
enseignants et panet invitant père de la
morandais oui vous avez avoué la
télévision l'a pratiquement tous tout
bâtiment non pratiquer la masturbation
mais non obama vous avez parlé de la
pitance du pauvre à l'âme et non mais
moi je ne suis pas langue de bois je dis
qu'il m'est arrivé d'être pauvre oui
voilà la pitance du pauvre est arrivé
d'être pauvre je suis pêcheur oui voilà
arrivé d'être mort excusez moi je vais
citer une petite phrase de groland sur
une image détournée sur le pape jean
paul ii tension racheté à la main qui
tremble on avait dit avoir une main
comme celle contre la masturbation sinon
alors jean choc passé du bon temps
non on monte alors quand même pas bien
donc vous avez avoué pratiquer la
masturbation ce que j'allais leur
attachement entre moustiques mais
entaché le dos du pauvre viendra vous
publiez alain de la morandais un livre
qui risque de faire encore plus
scandaleux c'est à peine le traité du
vrai combat chez jean claude lattès le
pitch c'est un homme mûr qui rencontre
un garçon de 20 ans passionnée par un
bruit verlaine et c'est la passion c'est
un thème littéraire qui est très ancien
qui remonte au 9 août il vient cher et
qui sert marguerite yourcenar tam
anosibe mais c'est dans cette tradition
chez ce que rencontrent beaucoup de
pédagogue salariés parce que ce que vous
oubliez de dire s'il suffit de serrer
très riche soyons honnêtes ce court
billet de dire c'est une passion chasse
oui attendait juste pas joli joli bond
en mairie
j'en ai je parle au nom hollande où je
prends aujourd'hui catholique comme moi
je prends je t'aime mon père je prend
alors tout comme témoin dans le social
ce personnage orlando y aller n'est toi
qui es seddikia l'aîné qui est écrivain
et chalon hétéro et qui s'appelle le
divin maître ça c'est l'aîné il ya le
cadet qui s'appelle l'elfe déjà bon
train dans lequel le fils est telle
qu'un sentiment général alors on avec
devon avait compris à rimbaud et
verlaine dès la première rencontre
évidemment il ya du trouble jeu bien sûr
je le diable est là non je me réfère aux
je me réfère aux textes qui étaient
selon adolescents blessés poussez trop
vite comme une tige tige est à la fois
ci s'il vous plaît si ready tiges que je
retenais instinctivement l'accent
farouche trop brûlant des mots qui se
pressaient à ma bouche de peur de
blesser de vie etc à l'embrasement ce
personnage marc certainement dès ses
premières heures captivé mais je n'en ai
aucune conscience éclairée jusqu'à ce
que je me surpris à le presser de venir
souper chez moi l'anti danse du pauvre
en lisant ça en tous cas ce qu'on peut
dire mon frère c'est que c'est très bien
conjuguer jusqu'à ce que je la surprise
ou qu'on veut nous convaincre du
lendemain soir pour lequel j'écris venue
du soir soit on entend des français qui
maîtrisent un pape exit donc voilà elle
avec lesquels j'ai dit à thierry à la
question c'est déjà comment vous un
prêtre et c'est la tentation qui est à
dire des choses aussi hard mais sépare
du tout quand même pas du tout une
séduction homosexuels mon père est alors
ça existe dans l'imparfait du subjonctif
pâquerettes je me délester du slip c'est
bien dit c'est parce qu'il m'a dit je
bandais bulli sont pour emprisonner le
dard devenu de plus en plus tempétueux
d'angres angie l'algérie qui imposerait
au moins les apparences de la défense
des classes comme j'ai effectué cette
opération en mettant de tournai debout
face au rocher un mouvement inopinée de
mon visage fille que mes lèvres des
floraire le gras chaud de la hautepierre
cette sensation si chaleureuse me
conduisit à appliquer la sodomie et la
bouche est l'organe impénitent contre la
surface entière du rocher cta et la fin
il jouit contre lorient à la fin sam oui
mais c'est bien quand je
sais s'appelle une fiction et la fiction
la question c'est est-ce que c'est une
question c'est que le professeur est ce
que c'est à vous d'écrire des livres
comme on s'y attendait ne le choque les
confidents tout le temps des tentations
quand tous les gens orlando vous n'êtes
pas un bouquet de catholiques comme on
faisait pas choquer oui je suis gentil
je dis qu'elle est on vraiment changer
mais vraiment vous venez de dire est est
en principe quand on sait qu on fait ça
on n'a pas le droit de répéter ce qu'on
a entendu vous venez de dire à l'instant
que vous devrez vous écrivez ce que vous
avez entendu dire et pas une confession
telles confidences mais je n'ai pas
changé c'est formidable
mais j'aime beaucoup les jésuites
monseigneur et franchement d'être
catholique je vous êtes choqués de voir
un prêtre qu'aujourd'hui écrit des
choses comme ça s'il ya quelqu'un qui
fait l'amour avec un rocher non
franchement je vous dire on en a vu des
vertes et des pas mûres surtout dans
cette émission barochez c'est la
première fois monseigneur anchois sa
cote est la vraie question c'est le
professeur résiste à la tentation
résister wii et qu'il est il est
parfaitement chaste évidemment ça finit
par lui dire je t'aime qu'on a manqué
les jeux passe rien entre je défends
l'abbé de la morandais a c'est une
tradition depuis la tentation de sous le
soleil de satan de bernanos ou la paix
donissan été tenté par le diable
simplement serrés écrit par le avec le
style de barbara cartland c'est la seule
différence et non il ya un moment où il
est a où il était à cuba bon le fameux
aînés alors ils tapent des gonzesses bon
gars et un moment quand même il se met
au lit avec un mec jugé
registre et régis tu sais ce que j'ai
oublié de dire ça je pense à vous savez
pas faire
avec ce qu'on ne dit pas vous ne dit pas
si le rocher d'accord ou pas
le rocher est il qu'on s'entend bien
c'est monaco c'est non il résiste bon
finalement en or thierry oui non
temps-mort tambon fait un break petit
motif de tension la saa
épuise petit break monseigneur plaqué
bref petit break c'est que ça se passe
c'est du temps à se demander si les
chaussures
fin du temps mort non non finalement mon
père oui oh jang bon il se tape pas le
prostitué mâle
malgré son envie malgré les sexes
turgescent de l'image y réfléchisse et
voir quand il revient en france alors ça
frédéric ça va vous intéresser
j'interviens aussi se tape un jury du
prix femina a donc si tu n'as il refuse
il résiste et refuse je voudrais vous
pascal à la femme gérait femina et elle
existe d'ailleurs elle lui dit tu
choisis entre moi et ton dieu ouais
choisi dieu évidemment pas photo c'est
bien ton ça s'appelle le traité du vrai
combat par alain de la morandais c'est
chez jean claude lattès voilà alors pour
aller un petit peu plus loin mon père
m'a encore plus il résiste il est juste
je pense qu'on va faire une interview
confession
alors
tu vas te coucher à kedar ce soir comme
d'habitude 00h30 1h ray la messe demain
tu as pensé oh oui oui le texte est prêt
ouais
quand tu passes à la télé oui c'est pour
dieu ou c'est pour toi toujours pour
dieu dis donc ça marche l'islam en ce
moment c'est quoi leur truc bah c'est de
mélanger jeu qu'on l'a fait trop
longtemps nous la politique et la
religion à part le vin de messe tu
prends de quoi comme drogue un peu de
champagne quand tu mon offre
manger des religieuses aient le droit
oui mais j'aime penser au paradis est
rentré que les baskets on sera pieds nus
si bien plus confortable on sera à poil
ça serait quoi pour toi le onzième
commandement ne fume pas de pétards mais
le pétard c'est pas il ya pire que le
pétain mais oui il ya bien pire ya dieu
c'était une connerie alors j'étais juste
avant et tu me rassures toi toujours que
moi j'ai vu des vidéos et des fous de
dieu qui se complètent ont allumé un
mois j'ai vu des témoins de jéhovah
quand même pas eu d'accident
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou